yo wassup everybody man Luigi here and
today I'm Lea telling you guys the best
build to get a lot of exp in fallout 4
now this is only going off of what is
confirmed that we know this isn't gonna
be going off of any speculations for
this build is gonna be really concrete
but we don't know everything so possibly
it isn't going to be the best build for
when the game comes out geez we'll know
more then so if we head on over to vault
111 dot-com which is a site that lets
you put in part points I've uses a
second to beat a video previously and it
lets you put in skill point and see the
perks that it goes with it you can see
my exp King setup here this is gonna be
a very intelligence heavy build the
reason for that being is that
intelligence increases the amount of XP
earned for just anything any action you
do you have higher intelligence you will
get more exp for I recommend going to 9
rather than 10 since you think hey it's
high intelligence wanting to go all out
intent is there a bobblehead
in the game we do know that and if we
want to use the bobbleheads that should
give you another another level in
whichever special stat that you get it
in so for the intelligence stat we're
gonna get another skill point in that
that'll bring it up to 10 it's kind of
unknown if you already have 10 you get a
bobblehead what happens and because that
is unknown we're gonna stick with 9 now
all of the other stats are basically
based on what perks they give so the big
ones are agility and charisma and I
guess lock-picking a little bit not like
tricking perception and strength and
luck and Durance aren't too big of a
deal
luck you don't do any exp from finding
these things is just to help you out
because you're not gonna be too deadly
strength you should get you speak from
making armor so I just put that in there
also armor make you stronger because
you're not gonna be to killing too
quickly and that can be dying to slow
over in perception we have lock-picking
and pickpocketing which should give you
a xp for completing those actions
pickpocketing maybe but a lock-picking
definitely so you have higher exp gain
you'll get more exp when you do those
tasks and give you a block picking perk
then you can do more lock picking also
charisma when you talk to people in
previous Fallout games if you use
charisma to entice them to do something
they wouldn't do if you didn't have a
high charisma you usually get xp for
that so these intelligence will give you
more XP and you'll have more
opportunities to get exp using careers
also animal friend which is pacifying an
animal I'm assuming that's gonna have an
XP value with it and so intelligence
will bump that that'll be more often and
really important is local either you can
see I haven't taken that perk because
local leader is about settlements
settlements won't be around level one so
you can get that perk a little later and
local leader is definitely a really
important perk to have for doing a lot
of settlement stuff and if you do a lot
of settlement stuff that'll definitely
get you exp I can't imagine doing a lot
of settlement stuff doesn't give you X
feet and so intelligence will buff that
going over to agility this is really
really cool mr. Sandman killing a
sleeping enemy or human ghoul or super
mutant specifically will give you
quadruple XP that's quad XP and that's
buffed up by intelligence already that's
getting a ton of XP also side note in
luck this perk right here potluck or at
least potluck is what this site calls it
I don't know if that I don't think
that's the name of it people are
speculating that that gives you that
randomly gives you the XP however it
gives you it has a higher chance
randomly giving you more exp when you
have low intelligence so it doesn't
really flow with this build and also
it's unconfirmed so that gets confirmed
I will actually probably add it to this
build just because it's gonna be giving
you more exp
even though it doesn't work super well
with intelligence so that's really
that's my video that's the build I hope
you guys have enjoyed this this is the
exp King currently for what we know it
is the best way to get exp in my opinion
and yeah so hope you guys enjoyed this
video check out more of my fallout 4
content I'll be posting a ton of stuff
about fallout 4 so if you're interested
in that keep checking on my channel and
thank you for watching peace out